now it is quite common to hear people
progressives in particular say that sex
actually doesn't have any intrinsic
value to it it doesn't have any
intrinsic specialness like if people
want to apply meaning to it on a
personal level they're welcome
to but when it comes down to it it's
just a social interaction you know you
can buy it you can sell it it's fine I
don't think anyone really believes that
I think almost no one actually believes
that and you can tell because people are
extraordinarily inconsistent in applying
this so people who for instance will say
that sex work is work no problem it's
just like working
McDonald's will not apply that to their
own personal lives or not even apply it
to other sort of similar issues in terms
of Law and policy so the example I give
in the book is sex for rent all of the
major political parties in the UK are
united in believing that landlords who
offer rooms in exchange for sexual
favors are are or should be breaking the
law they're all United in saying we
should have firmer laws on it this is
particularly postco because there was
sort of a rash of landlords doing this
it's the same in other Western countries
as well um these are exactly the same
parties you know like the Liv Dems for
instance condemn sex for rent and think
we should decriminalize the sex industry
it's the same thing you know it's just
Goods you know being exchanged for
sexual access it's exactly the same
thing and similarly you know people who
will again say that sex his work that
that um you know really buy into the
sexual disenchantment idea rhetorically
very upset about any perceived sexual
impropriety in their own
workplaces you know like having any kind
of
um being T you know being touched by a
male colleague being asked out on a date
like that stuff is very serious and is
not at all comparable to just other
forms of nonsexual interaction but sex
work is work you know and I think that I
think that inconsistency is a result of
the fact that actually sexual
disenchantment just isn't
true basically no one really thinks it's
true but the problem is that if you um
are trying to rationalize it all and you
are applying kind of utility brain to
the world it's quite hard to um it's
quite hard to articulate it's quite hard
to rationalize it comes from a very
visceral place which is a bit
inconvenient if you're trying to apply
that kind of you know very long iCal
worldview the fact that people have
emotional responses to things that are
are somewhat inconvenient you know but
the truth of it is that people don't
feel that sex is the same as other
social interactions people absolutely
feel that sex has some unique status
which is of course why I mean thinking
from a feminist perspective which is why
rape is so uniquely bad which is why
sexual harassment is so uniquely bad if
you don't think sex is special you can't
think any of those things have special
status either and I think that that idea
of sexual
disenchantment is bad for everyone but
it's really bad for women
why partly because of physical imbalance
between the Sexes of the fact that it's
only women who get
pregnant women have to suffer the side
effects of hormonal
contraception um women are much smaller
and weaker than men which means that any
heterosexual encounter if you've got a
man and woman Alone Together the woman's
going to be almost always the more
physically vulnerable party so there's
that kind of risk inherent to sexual
encounters that women experience that
men can't experience in the same way
there's also the psychological stuff and
that's more
controversial because the push towards
um kind of radical equality within
feminism in Liberal
feminism has also included pushing back
very hard against the idea that there
are any innate differences between the
Sexes on a psychological level and some
of that is coming from a good place it
is clearly the it's clearly the case
that in various periods in history
pseudoscientific ideas about women's
intellectual inferiority in particular
or emotional inferiority have been used
against women this is clearly true um
that does not however mean that those
differences don't exist at all and
actually as decades have gone by and
we've got more and more scientific
research on this it actually becomes
more and more apparent that those
differences do exist on average right
the on average thing is something that
people often can't wrap their heads
around well they can they just don't
want to well people can when it comes to
something like the ADV the example I
give is like you know if we say that
Germans are on average taller than
people from Spain people are like oh
yeah fine no one says oh but I know a
really tall guy from Spain that
disproves your thesis you know this is
the nature of bell curves um there are
all sorts of ways in which the certain
psychological traits differ on on the
bell curve basis between men and women
the one that's most important for my
purposes is the trait that psychologist
called
sociosexuality which is not quite the
same as sex drive you can be you know
highing one low on the other but social
sexuality is about your um desire for
casual sex basically how much you want
to have sex with a variety of people how
quickly you want to jump into bed with
someone now look I'm not an expert but
I'm going to guess men are more prone to
have a higher rate of that cross
culturally trans historically yes wow
yeah I'm a genius how did I work that
out I know how dare you know she do
things but you know yes I mean anyone
who's like got eyes and lived in the
world can tell that the clearly is that
difference between men and women even if
there are lots of outliers on an
individual level I mean just because you
know someone's sex doesn't mean you know
their level of socios sexuality but at
the population level you see it you see
it for instance in the fact that all
almost all sex buyers everywhere in the
world are male MH because obviously the
people who are is that tale of high
sociosexuality is like all men right um
there are I'm going to say them even
more controversial than you but
basically if you want to understand what
men are actually like just look at gay
men right how much sex do they have and
how many partners do they have on
average compared to the average
heterosexual man and you kind of get
like gay men are actually the real men
because they're unrestrained by women
yes yeah absolutely it's really that
simple yeah it's how men would behave if
women w a limiting factor exactly yeah
and I mean it's interesting in if you
look at the survey data on gay men of
which there's quite a lot because it
comes out of like um sexual health
research and stuff what you have is
actually like a goodish of men who are
just as monogamous as lesbians M and you
have a lot of men in the
middle and then you have a proportion
who are really promiscuous and because
there isn't the limiting factor of of
women saying no those men are way more
promiscuous than promiscuous straight
men yeah can ever be because they just
have so much more opportunity um but you
know but that but that portion of like
would be promiscuous straight men still
exists it's just they've got the
complexity of having to deal with female
Choice um which makes the whole
heterosexual you know dating marriage
scene that much more
complex